shovel and just plain fat taxes now if
you're Santa
again downhill get something going to
who by the way yoke it's does not have a
turnover either here storms for
three-foot Bryn Forbes it's a five-point
game
quiets down the crowd fork we've got
seventeen and really shoot that ball
with a lot of confidence
we're in Forbes is three out of four
from behind the arc Murray and yoke it's
the dynamic duo yo kids on the tape just
plowing his way in doesn't get the
bounce that the scores flying high
Millsaps got it he is DeRozan it's a
jump ball
nuggets wanting a foul there the rosin
came in late he'll jump it against
Millsap nice drive by yo kitsch and then
Millsap comes in and just there's this
grump for the ball they're battling for
it and I like you call a jump ball now
one good job referees maybe had an
Armour to tell you we're here for arms
shoulder that's ok call a jump ball a
lot of contact Spurs got away with one
right there they'll jump it Millsap in
DeRozan and Millsap - yigit's shot clock
is at nine yoga can assist away from a
triple double Murray with forms on him
gets loose Murray no and it's Millsap
with an offensive rebound how about Paul
Millsap needing the ball back twice he
goes and gets it just wants it more
nuggets a plus six on the offensive
glass yo kids two three short and I
think gay tux and last or Diddy nope
that's gonna be San Antonio ball yeah
that was off Tori Craig I think Spurs
ball down five Nicola yoke it's trying
to play the entirety of this fourth
quarter he only did that twice in the
regular season they both resulted in
Denver losses just 2 for 19 from behind
the arc the Nuggets guy gets something
now going to the hole spin by throws at
gets three old and hangs on the rim
there's a foul call I think the
officials may want to come together on
this one the rosin crab the rim with his
offhand it was gonna be a big call he's
taking this to the rack foul on the
occasion I know I called the foul I
think before he grabbed the room he
definitely grabbed the rim but the call
in the fall right there prior to him
trying to pull it do a pull-up and jam
it in there
so yoke it's thought to the foul that's
number five on yogurts
and the Rossum misses the free throw
what happens here is that he does grab
the rim I think they called the foul
first had he grabbed the rim first that
would have been offensive interference
and it would have negated the foul right
he they called the foul first
15 for DeRozan in the second half he's
got 19 for the game it's back to a
four-point Denver game and the way this
is going first one tonight he might win
at Kent we got a minute
nine remaining game seven first round
Western Conference Murray gives it up
milk it spins kicks it here's Harris 6
on the shot clock
no and author it's able to save it for
us on the breakout and Forbes will throw
it down with two hands it's a two-point
game
timeout Denver the Spurs will not die
Denver pushes it to eight
San Antonio comes right back Nuggets up
a pair with the ball in half number to
set us up here Kevin
sideout fort Denver as they advance the
ball they normally close to that mid
screen roll with Murray and Yogi's but
I'd like to see y'all pitch in the post
now they haven't got much I that mid
screen or all with he and Marie lay lean
in the open she's been missing his
little runners there but they're gonna
go with it again this has have been been
their bread and butter so let's see what
they do
Spurs don't have a style to give here yo
kitch gives it back Murray
shot clock to 9 here's Murray off one
foot
[Applause]
in the launch of one foot four-point
game DeRozan goes milk attention and the
Nuggets start to step it now huge
possession
little over three seconds separating the
shot clock in the game clock
no fouls to give
yo cats has a triple double vowel shot
clock at two
Murray's got to go Big Shot up and it
goes and that is going to take us
[Applause]
Nuggets for the first time since 2009
advance in the NBA Playoffs
[Applause]